so wait you ask them is it three
questions all your guests do you pay for
all my guests I like to do this a kind
of subconscious test that tells you we
do it Timmy I'm gonna do it to you okay
so this is a okay if you're dating
someone interviewing a new friend
interviewing a new co-worker this is a
test that helps you figure out sort of
who someone is on a subconscious level
so the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
nervous I'm you should be I'm gonna ask
you your favorite animal don't say Henry
don't say your dog because that's what I
want to do I want to say my dog I I want
to say my dog I wanted to say my horse
your favorite animal the one that you
admire wolf that's what rate one and
three characteristics about a wolf mmm
why you like them um I like him because
they're strong because they're fast
uh-huh and I like them because they
travel in packs I like a buddy system
I love okay that's genius the second
thing is your favorite article of
clothing and it doesn't have to be
something you're wearing I was like oh
like a ball gown is it a pair of socks I
ended up doing a hoodie because they're
like classic yeah they're warm they're
sort of gender-neutral I like that like
what would be your favorite article of
clothing jeans jeans yeah they are
George well there were minor stretchy
[Laughter]
mine are very stretchy in those
pregnancy lady you know what we're nuts
pregnant I fought about it afterwards
because I was like this is too much you
should stop eating and workout blog with
the tie the tie around the top no no I
like regular Joe I like regular jeans
I'm a jeans girl but I like them because
they are there they kind of they're like
second skin yeah I like that and I'm
classic I'm a mom and I'm running around
all the time and then we have a ranch
Montana so you really don't wear ball
gowns in Montana
um it's a little weird and then your
favorite body of water it can be a
swimming pool a river a lake is I picked
the new river in West Virginia because I
used to spend time there as a kid
I would say rivers why named my daughter
River so I better like it
characteristics of a river I picked that
too so I like that they connect all
bodies of water
I've heard yeah I think that connected
sometimes they're like rough sometimes
they're not like but I like a rushing
river I like to hear the sound I like
the sound of it it's calming okay you
know and I'm gonna tell you what all of
this means so hey I am ready it's not
okay your favorite animal is how you see
yourself
Oh what was it strong shine I travel
impact and your favorite article of
clothing reveals how other people
perceive you Owens
yes very comfortable with herself may be
far too comfortable does he come and
then your favorite body of water is how
you view sex yeah you know what it works
[Applause]
I like it watching connects oh yeah very
good it's good well you actually pass
with flying colors because a lot of
times the way that you perceive yourself
and the way other people perceive you is
wildly different so there's some kind of
disconnect like I picked honey badgers
my favorite animal like gritty knows me
I know cuz I perceive myself that way
but then everyone else perceives me as a
hoodie like comfortable warm so I was
like oh I need to like do some work on
catching up on the way I perceive myself
this is the coolest
has ever happened on this show I'm gonna
so do this to my friends that didn't see
this episode it's a good way to find red
flags if you're dating a new person give
them this quiz if you ask them their
favorite animal and they say like leach
or like or like I know a lot of guys
will say we're air which means like
eight months of sleeping like or if the
girl if it's a girl you're not and she
says genes know that she's gonna get
real comfortable after you're married
she asked me three questions and it was
awesome
oh and she does this in her podcast good
for you can she ask you three questions
okay okay
don't be nervous I mean you will be
judged but domain RS I'm just kidding
questions don't overthink it I'm gonna
ask you your favorite animal your
favorite article of clothing in your
favorite body of water okay so what
would you say is your favorite animal my
favorite animal is a lion oh good one
and what are three characteristics of a
lion that you like confident mmhmm yeah
strong huh and allow I love it what
would you say is your favorite article
of clothing it can be anything from like
a tuxedo to a hoodie to your favorite
pair of socks I mean I love a good
jacket so yeah
like a blazer or like a jacket blue jean
jacket jean jacket that's a great one
with the one I like to wear is a I mean
it's fly I mean that's not a
characteristic it feels good and it
makes my arms look nice yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and what would you say is your favorite
body of water can be a lake upon a
specific tree or whatever
Lake Michigan oh great one no specific
what are some characteristics of Lake
Michigan that you like oh it's beautiful
yeah I'm a winter person so it's colder
by the lake okay yeah we need one more
characteristic of Lake Michigan I don't
know what another characteristic of a
lake that's that's all I get are they
call me bill or they come or they Lake
Michigan is huge huge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay your favorite animal is how you
perceive yourself you are a lion you're
confident you're strong and you're loud
yes that's how you perceive yourself
major red flags no red flags I mean this
a little bit your favorite article of
clothing is weight other people perceive
you jean jacket fly feels good makes my
arms look your favorite body of water is
how you view sex which is beautiful
called in huge
[Applause]
Oh
oh my god I love this show oh I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this